Привіт, любі п’ятикласники.
Ми з вами знову зустрілися
на уроці української мови.
З вами я – пані Юлія!
Це прикольно!
Я в школі навчався більш-менш добре.
Любі учні, щиро дякую вам за
всі виконані домашні завдання,
які ви надіслали на мою електронну пошту.
Лише за два дні я одержала
637 листів від вас.
Зізнаюся, я ще не встигла перечитати всі
ваші листи
і мені дуже складно визначити
кращий чи гірший,
але все ж таки хочу назвати - перший лист
я одержала від Світланки.
Вона розповідає про свою домашню
улюбленицю.
Отож, нам потрібно визначити
однорідні члени речення.
- Ви вже помітили їх?
- Так.
- Прошу!
- Грайлива, кмітлива і симпатична.
- Грайлива...це в нас однорідні…
Грайлива, кмітлива і симпатична.
Це є однорідні…?
- Додатки.
- Присудки!
Вона є грайлива, є кмітлива,
є симпатична – однорідні присудки.
Ще помітили?
- Підтримує і не дозволяє…
- Підтримує і…
не дозволяє нудьгувати.
Які це члени речення?
- Які?
- Однорідні…присудки!
Другий лист, який я одержала,
був від Надії.
- Які тут члени речення?
- Мила і талановита.
- Це однорідні означення.
Третій лист.
- Тут розумна та кмітлива.
- Які це члени речення?
- Однорідні…присудки?
Ні! Шая яка? розумна
та яка? кмітлива.
Це однорідні означення.
Любить грати з…
- Зі мною та м’ячем.
- Які це члени речення?
- Я здогадуюсь, що теж однорідні?
- Теж однорідні, які?
На які питання відповідають?
- З ким? чим?
- Так.
- Додатки.
Правильно – однорідні додатки.
Далі було ще дуже-дуже багато листів,
але вразив мене останній лист,
від Анастасії.
Вона надіслала одразу чотири світлини
і розповіді про чотирьох домашніх
улюбленців.
Зачитаю речення про папужку.
- Отож, однорідні члени речення?
- Спокійний, добрий, уважний, цікавий.
- Це?
- Однорідні прикметники.
- Ні! Такого немає.
- Присудки.
- Однорідні присудки, так.
Тому що є спокійний, є добрий,
є уважний і є цікавий.
- Інші однорідні члени речення…
- Полюбляє кого? що? – їжу…
- Їжу, смаколики, овес, пшоно,
фрукти та овочі.
- Це однорідні?
- Допоможіть мені.
- Додатки!
Звертаю вашу увагу!
Яке слово узагальнює
однорідні члени речення?
- Їжу?
- Їжу, так!
Це – узагальнювальне слово, і воно
стоїть перед однорідними членами речення.
Отже, ставимо двокрапку.
Дорослі й малі – усі його люблять.
Однорідними є?
- Дорослі й малі.
- Так, це які члени речення?
- Відповідають на хто? що?
Це, Кириле?
- Додатки.
- Хто? що? – Називний відмінок…
- Присудки?
- Однорідні підмети!
Дорослі й малі – це однорідні підмети,
і усі його люблять.
Усі – це узагальнювальне слово
(узагальнює дорослі і малі).
Зверніть увагу, де воно розташоване
в реченні?
- Після…
- Після однорідних членів речення.
Отже, ставимо тире.
Такого листа я одержала від пані Анни.
Вона написала про свійських тварин.
Ваше завдання.
Щоб вам було легше виконувати це завдання,
я пропоную занотувати.
Розгорніть свої зошити.
Вам потрібно визначити
однорідні члени речення
та узагальнювальні слова.
Та сказати, якими членами речення вони є.
- Знайшли?
- Так.
- Прошу!
- Є багато свійських тварин…
- Тварин – це узагальнювальне слово.
- Однорідні – курей, гусей та корівок.
- Так. Які це члени речення?
- Відповідає на питання кого? що?
- Кого? чого?
- Додатки.
- Правильно, це однорідні додатки.
Курей, гусей та корівок – однорідні
додатки.
Тварин як узагальнювальне слово – теж
додаток.
Зверніть увагу на розділовий знак.
Чому ми ставимо двокрапку?
- Бо узагальнююче слово – тварин.
- Після якого ставиться двокрапка.
- Так. Однорідні члени речення стоять
після узагальнювального слова,
тому ставимо двокрапку.
Наступне.
- Так само, узагальнювальним словом
є ім’я,
після якого теж стоїть двокрапка
перед однорідними членами речення.
- Так! Які це члени речення?
- Це підмети?
- Немає кого? що?
- Теж додатки.
Це однорідні додатки!
Ще однорідні члени речення?
- Травичка, сіно, вода. Усе – це
узагальнювальне…
- Усе – узагальнювальне слово.
- Так. Воно стоїть після однорідних членів
речення, тому перед ним ставиться тире.
- Ставимо тире.
Які це члени речення?
- Травичка, сіно, вода – це підмети.
- Правильно, однорідні підмети.
Ще знайшли однорідні члени речення?
- Так. З’являються всюди:
на подвір’ї, у хліві, біля ставу.
Узагальнювальне – всюди,
однорідні – подвір’ї, у хліві, біля ставу.
- На подвір’ї, у хліві, біля ставу.
- Відповідає на питання де?
- Це?
- Обставина.
- Правильно, однорідні обставини.
Узагальнювальне слово – всюди, яке стоїть
перед однорідними членами речення.
Тому – двокрапка.
Нова тема нашого уроку:
«Звертання. Поширені
та непоширені звертання».
Разом із нами на сьогоднішньому уроці
будуть їжачки.
Про що наш урок?
Погляньте уважно на ці речення.
Кольором виділено звертання.
- У першому реченні де звертання?
Друзі.
На початку речення. Після
звертання ми що ставимо?
- Кому.
- Так. У другому реченні?
- Любі учні.
- Де?
- У середині речення.
І коми?
З обох боків.
Так. У третьому реченні?
Наприкінці – їжачки.
- У кінці речення, і кому ставимо
перед звертанням.
В кінці речення – розділовий знак
цього речення.
У нашому випадку – знак питання.
У цих реченнях звертаннями є:
Сергію та сестричко.
Вжито їх у формі кличного відмінка.
Звертаю вашу увагу, що звертання
не є членом речення!
Отже, ми ніяк його не підкреслюємо.
В усному мовленні
звертання виділяємо паузами.
Звертання має таки види
- поширене та непоширене
Поширене звертання
складається з двох і більше слів.
Наприклад - рідна мово, земле моя.
Рідна мово, земле моя -
в них по два слова.
Непоширене звертання
складається лише з одного слова.
Наприклад - мово, земле.
Нумо практикувати!
Я пропоную прочитати цей фрагмент тексту
у ролях.
Я читатиму слова автора.
Слова зайчика читає...
Ви будете зайчиком, Кирило,
а слова їжачка читатиме Костянтин.
- Домовилися?
- Так.
Сіренький, гладенький
зайчик сказав їжакові:
- Який у тебе, братику,
некрасивий колючий одяг!
- То є так, - відповідає їжак, -
проте мої колючки, милий зайчику,
рятують мене від зубів собаки та вовка.
Чи служить і тобі так
добре твоє сіреньке хутро?
Зайчик замість відповіді тільки зітхнув.
Хочу звернути увагу на наголоси:
колючкИ і правильний наголос – хУтро.
Що ж, шукаємо звертання.
- Перше звертання,
як ми бачимо – це братику.
- Так! Де воно розміщене в реченні?
- У середині речення.
Відповідно, з обох боків - коми.
- Звертання у першому реченні – братику.
Воно знаходиться у середині речення,
тому з обох боків ми ставимо коми.
Це непоширене звертання,
бо складається з одного слова.
- Правильно. Ще є звертання?
- Так! Милий зайчику. Це поширене
звертання, тому що це два слова.
Воно також стоїть у середині речення,
тому з обох боків виділяється комами.
- Правильно!
Ми вже з’ясували, що звертання може стояти
на початку речення, у середині, наприкінці
Залежно від цього ставимо розділові знаки.
- Які розділові знаки при цьому ставимо?
Коми.
Отже, якщо на початку речення…
- З обох боків.
- Якщо у кінці речення?
Якщо у середині речення?
З обох боків.
Якщо у кінці речення?
Перед звертанням.
Так, а в кінці речення – розділовий знак
цього речення,
залежно від мети висловлювання.
Де розміщено звертання?
У середині речення.
Якщо звертання стоїть у кінці речення,
то ставимо розділовий знак, якого потребує
інтонація цього речення.
Це може бути знак оклику,
знак питання чи крапка.
Звертання на початку.
Вимовляємо з підвищеною інтонацією: Люди!
Тому ставимо знак оклику, а наступне
речення пишемо з великої літери.
Схематично все те, про що ми з
вами говорили, можна зобразити так.
Я отримала речення від п’ятикласників
гімназії-інтернату
міста Хуста Закарпатської області.
Їх мені надіслала вчителька – пані
Олеся Калинич.
Прочитаймо ці речення,
знайдімо звертання, визначмо:
поширене чи непоширене
і прокоментуймо розділові знаки.
Прошу, Костянтине!
Люба Широ, ти найлагідніша кицька.
Тут у нас звертання: Люба Широ.
Воно стоїть на початку,
тому кома стоїть наприкінці слова Широ.
Так.
Це поширене звертання,
бо складається з двох слів.
Так. Дякую!
Пухнаста Тіно - теж
звертання на початку речення.
Це поширене звертання, тому що два слова.
Кома після звертання, після імені Тіна.
- Тіно, так! Ви звернули увагу,
в якому відмінку вживаються звертання?
У Кличному.
У кличному відмінку.
Так, дякую! Наступне.
- Любий мій папужко! Наша дружба вічна!
Звертання – Любий мій папужко!
Це звертання вжито з інтонацією окличною,
тому ми ставимо знак оклику.
- Так, підвищена інтонація…
- Це поширене звертання.
- Дякую! Далі.
- Мій котику, напевно, я й тебе переведу
на карантин, щоб не лазив до сусідів.
Звертання на початку речення – мій котику.
Це є поширене звертання,
і після нього стоїть кома.
- Правильно, наступне.
- Хатіко, ти такий милий, лови кісточку!
Тут звертання – Хатіко.
Воно непоширене,
складається з одного слова.
На початку речення стоїть, тому в нас одна
кома наприкінці.
- Так, після звертання.
- Люба Мері, будь ласка, не заважай мені
навчатися та не сиди на моїх зошитах!
Люба Мері – це звертання.
Це поширене звертання, тому що є два слова
і після нього стоїть кома: після Мері.
- Правильно.
- Наступне це в нас від Олександри:
Шановний пане їжачку Джеку!
Ти знаєш, що таке узагальнювальне слово?
Напевно, він знає.
Я вважаю, що звертання – це перше речення:
Шановний пане їжачку Джеку!
Воно поширене, бо складається з двох…
навіть більше слів.
- Зі скількох слів?
- Шановний, пане, їжачку, Джеку –
чотирьох слів.
- Чотири слова.
- Тому в нас знак оклику.
- З підвищеною інтонацією
і ставимо знак оклику.
Відповідно, наступне речення як окреме
речення – з великої літери.
Гаразд.
Нумо практикувати!
Знайдіть звертання,
поясніть розділові знаки.
Доброго вам здоров'ячка, шановні читачі!
- Тут у нас звертання…
- У цьому реченні.
- У цьому реченні в нас
звертання – шановні читачі!
Воно поширене: з двох слів.
Стоїть наприкінці речення,
тому одна кома перед звертанням
і наприкінці знак оклику.
- Так!
Дозвольте відрекомендуватися: я
Фунь-Фунь із роду Ерінацеус еуропеус.
Іншими словами - їжак
звичайний, європейський.
- Є звертання у цьому реченні?
- Немає.
Я страшенно щасливий, що мені
випала честь відкрити вам, шановні читачі,
всю правду про життя моєї славетної
родини - родини їжаків. Фунь-фунь!
- В цьому реченні у нас звертання
у середині – шановні читачі.
Поширене звертання:
складається з двох слів,
і ми ставимо коми з обох боків.
Ці речення – про книгу Олексія Потапенка,
відомого як Потап.
Книга має назву «Пан Їжак».
Наступна книга – Тетяни Стус
«Їжак Вільгельм».
Ваше завдання:
знайти звертання, визначити поширене
чи непоширене кожне з них.
- Почнемо спочатку.
Перше звертання у першому реченні – Друзі,
після якого має стояти кома.
- Так. Звертання це?
- Непоширене.
- Гаразд.
- Друге звертання, яке я знайшов – це
любий читачу.
Це поширене звертання,
і ми маємо поставити кому
перед любий та після читачу.
- Правильно.
Це звертання?
- Поширене.
- Так! Ще є звертання?
Так. В останньому реченні.
Друже – це непоширене звертання.
Воно стоїть у середині речення, тому перед
друже і після потрібно поставити кому.
- Правильно.
Зверніть, будь ласка,
увагу на передостаннє речення.
Воно має однорідні члени речення,
узагальнювальне слово.
Прокоментуйте, будь ласка,
розділові знаки в цьому реченні.
- Історія маленького Вільгельма розповідає
про що? – про мрію, дружбу та віру…
- Розділові знаки які?
- Треба поставити кому після мрію.
- Мрію...кома, так.
- Після мрію кома та слова віру теж…
- Ні!
- Після слова Образи треба поставити
двокрапку.
- Правильно! Чому двокрапка?
- Тому що це узагальнювальне слово.
- Так, узагальнювальне слово перед
однорідними членами.
- Якими є: світло, доброта і
власна неповторність.
Знаєте, звідки діти вперше дізнаються
про звертання?
З казок.
Зверніться до тих тваринок,
що є на цьому колажі
і подякуйте їм за яскравий світ казки.
Запросіть тих, кого тут немає.
Оскільки, на жаль,
завершується час нашого уроку,
я пропоную вам, шановні телеглядачі,
скласти самостійно
речення після уроку, усно.
Нумо підбивати підсумки.
Чекатиму на ваші дописи.
Дякую за увагу.
Шануймо одне одного
й вивчаймо українську.
- Дякую вам!
- Дякуємо!
Мене огорнули теплі…
Зараз, вибачте...
Чаще… частіше розмовляю…
Ви просто волаєте і я волаю.
Коротше, ми тут надовго.
По-перше, мені було дуже соромно…
По-перше, мені було дуже соромно,
бо я дуже погано розмовляю
українською мовою, як ви чуєте.
Моє слабке місце – це наголоси,
і мене пані Юля у класі часто-часто
виправляла. Фух!
Щоб вам не було в майбутньому соромно,
вивчайте українську мову у ваш час!
Вибачте, пані Юліє, якщо ви це дивитеся,
за мою українську мову!
Пані Юля – дуже гарна вчителька.
Вона все дуже доступно пояснює,
все зрозуміло.
Чесно кажучи, буду відвертим:
я не навчався в школі.
Я дуже погано вчився, але всі вчителі
мене знали, тому що я був найгірший.
Це моє досягнення.
Я не агітую. Так – погано!
Так робити не можна!
Це цікаво, я такого ще ніколи не бачив.
Це все тут, тобто,
можна переключитися і робити.
Я вважаю… У цьому реченні
звертання – це любі друзі.
Воно посередині…
У цьому реченні звертання знаходиться
у середині речення – любі учні,
з обох боків ми виділяємо комами,
бо це звертання.
Звертання у середині речення – любі учні.
Це є просте звертання,
так як це два слова… Поширене!
Заново…
Це поширене звертання,
бо воно складається з більше ніж…
Воно складається з двох слів,
тому це поширене звертання.
Пані Юля!